[Music]
thank you
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 161 I believe
that's right yep 161 that's good it is
very good oh wait we don't know yet that
is that fair point yeah um it is
February 11th you are you are Dr Heather
hiring I am Dr Brett Weinstein wait
you're not using our credentials to
sneak some sciency stuff in and confuse
people are you
that I hadn't decided yet but no that
was not my intent on revealing that we
have a credential or two in fact I I'll
just say I don't believe in these
credentials it happens that your
credential in my credential do mean
something but the fact of having one
doesn't mean much at all that's
something that it's a distinction that
seems lost in a lot of people readily
apparent inside uh the economy I will
say before we get to any of that though
yes uh I am
super excited are you yes about February
11th in exactly number 161 what about no
about February 11th okay pause uh unless
my calculations are incorrect which they
might be I don't think they are okay I
don't think they are I think in this
case I've just uh I've nailed it we are
more than halfway through winter no
matter how you measure that whether you
measure uh from the winter solstice to
the Spring Equinox well no if you
measure it from if you if you measure
the winter solstice as Midwinter
then it's not winter anymore
hold on hold on you may have got me here
yeah
in the worst case in the worst case
scenario we are now halfway through the
winter of uh 20. the northern hemisphere
of 2023 that began in 2020. yeah and as
somebody who has um this is a
fascinating closet prepper instincts
thing about being halfway through winter
it's it's one of those uh closets that
you build into a room that doesn't have
a deep Vape it's not a real hidden
closet but
um but yeah I'm a slightly closeted
prepper type
um the halfway marks through winter
is actually a big deal because it means
that if things were to go Haywire in a
way that would require your prepping and
would reveal all of the ways in which
you had not gotten all the way to fully
prepped
um the chances that you could Cobble
your way through what remains are all
the greater so yeah I mean for instance
we don't live in a place that's all that
cold oh there it gets plenty cold and it
snows and everything but uh we
definitely have enough sun sun
to get us through the winter at this
point um no matter how how cold it gets
yeah and uh you know the relationship
between wood and sun is a good one
because it really is like a solid sun
and that came from stacked I never know
which son I was talking about yeah
um
I think I do know which sign you were
talking about you were yeah exactly that
one um but anyway you know you take your
choice but uh but that one yeah it's
stored up in the wood and um so anyway
I'm just I'm excited that uh we appear
it's not a slam dunk but it looks like
we're gonna survive the winner nice yeah
May the same be true for all of you who
are listening and watching absolutely to
you and yours all right so we're gonna
we're gonna get into it uh quickly today
but just a few reminders right off the
top first
um we are not going to do a q a this
week uh and if you were looking for some
Dark Horse content instead during that
time you could pick up our book Hunter
gathers Guide to the 21st century or
check out Natural Selections this week I
republished an essay that was originally
published in a literary magazine
that's now defunct the essay is called
Memories of a mugging and it's an
exploration of the sensory nature of
memory and told
um through a story that actually
happened to me and three of my students
on my first study abroad trip in Ecuador
where we were mugged at knife point in
Quito and it's uh I'm very fond of this
this piece and it got me thinking about
a number of other other things as
thinking about memory will do and
thinking about the science of memory
also will do
uh okay we are supported by you
we encourage you to join our patreons to
subscribe to the channels wherever you
are watching YouTube
Odyssey uh if you are listening only and
you're listening on Apple podcasts or
wherever
um definitely subscribe and share and
like and uh a reminder that on our
patreons you get access to our Discord
server where there's a great community
of people having conversations in all
sorts of modalities uh speaking of the
senses by text by Audio by video
and they don't uh they don't care what
you look like or how old you are or
where you come from or what you think so
long as you're respectful and recognize
the humanity of all of us so I'm trying
to make sense let's try trying to make
sense indeed
uh so uh and finally for top of the hour
stuff we have sponsors we are very
grateful to our sponsors we start uh
start these podcasts every week with
three ads and then we don't do any more
throughout the episode so without
further Ado here we go our first sponsor
this week is Vivo Barefoot they make
shoes made for feed everyone should try
these shoes most shoes are made for
someone's idea of what feet should be
vivos however are made by people who
actually know feet and that sounds
obvious don't we don't know if you know
most of most of us don't it turns out
including many shoemakers who are
thinking about what they what person's
foot in a shoe to look like as opposed
to what a foot actually is and what it
needs to do in order to for a person
wearing these shoes to remain healthy
those people who do it badly are are
shoe mockers
they're making a mockery of shoes is
what I think is going on
all right I've thrown a monkey wrench
into the works well it seems to me that
Schumacher is either the German or the
Yiddish pronunciation of I think
it must be it must be right in which
case mocker
I'm not I'm not sure this totally works
because mocker is maker in at least some
related language well I think it does
work as long as that would be the word
for shoe in Germany so I don't even know
I don't even know what that is I I
apologize to our uh our native German
speakers but otherwise I think it's
dance and not the Yiddish speakers there
aren't that many Yiddish speakers I need
to apologize to them anyway
I do but I think it's more or less
academic happy Shabbat everyone
um uh a word is spreading about these
shoes and we've talked about this before
but I was approached by a stranger this
last week who recognized the shoes I was
wearing and asked if they are as good as
she had heard I was of course wearing
the vivos that I wear most times that
I'm out and yes they are they are indeed
as good as she had heard and as good as
we are telling you they are right now
this is again Vivo barefoots we love
these shoes they're beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing they cause
no pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're fantastic
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution not just so are our
ears their feet also yes your feet your
ears our ears our feet but we're only
talking about feet at the moment and
ears apparently
humans evolve to walk move and run bear
so if you want to talk about ears you
can go read my memories of a mugging
peace senses and all this yeah
um our ears are the product of yes
millions of years of evolution as well
and then yeah I'm not going to go there
okay modern shoes they're overly
cushioned and strangely shaped of
negatively impacted foot function and
are contributing to a Health crisis
people move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
I you know so this is not a standard ad
read but
as long as we're talking about here
right
um so one of the um
diagnostic characteristics of mammals a
so-called synapomorphy is having these
three middle ear bones which have moved
have migrated from being Gill arches in
early vertebrates and we don't have Gill
arches anymore as many of you who will
have noticed and some of the the
posterior Gill arches have moved some of
the skeletal elements of them have moved
and become our middle ear bones that
have allowed us as mammals to hear
really well
and I it raises the question for me of
what has happened with the um tarsals
and metatarsals in the feet there's a
you know there's less there's going to
be less modification at one level uh
because there's no you know Gill arches
to be transformed to move up into the
skull and such or into the upper part of
the skull but
um
but obviously like a horse's hoof with a
you know the reduction of digits and
such uh and the movement of us from
being quadrupedal to bipedal is going to
have transformed our feet bones a fair
bit and thus there may well be like
there are other Downstream negative
Health consequences of being bipedal and
then sitting down a lot that they're
likely going to be a lot of a lot of
foot concerns as well that are
specifically addressed by the issues
that is a huge amount of stuff going on
in hands and feet yeah which I learned a
great deal about when you and I became
interested in the hobbits of Flores
Island there's a very interesting
distinctions in the hands of humans and
human ancestors from our pre-human ape
ancestors yeah anyway it's probably not
the place but anyway it is a fascinating
question because the hand really isn't
what you think it is nor is the Foot
Right all of those
are not incidentally separate they are
functionally separate totally okay let
me just um if if anyone thought like
wait what did he say that's
homophoresciensis from Flores Island in
eastern in the Indonesian archipelago in
eastern Indonesia
which is a great story that we should
get back to it we should yeah probably
not today we're not even halfway through
the first ad
okay
um
modern shoes they're overly cushioned
and strangely shape have negatively
impacted foot function and are
contributing to a Health crisis people
move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
it's not an excuse though just get
better shoes try vivos enter Vivo
Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes are
designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up put
strength increases by 60 in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop certainly been the case for all of
us in our family
Barefoot has a great range of Footwear
for kids and adults and for every
activity from hiking to training and
everyday wear they're a certified B Corp
that is pioneering regenerative business
principles and their Footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials where
they aim to protect the natural world so
you can run wild in it go to
vivobarefoot.com Darkhorse to get an
exclusive offer of 15 off additionally
all new customers get a 100-day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com slash Darkhorse for
your 15 off offer you know what I
appreciate my vivos most
now when I have to put on regular shoes
right I realize that they are closer to
ski boots than they should be oh the
other shoes yes the other shoes the
other shoes are closer to ski boots and
they should be and vivos
um are not they're not you definitely
feel uh on the other hand you don't want
to ski them
I have not tried that yeah okay even
just attached the only negative thing I
can really come up with yeah don't don't
try to scan them
okay our second sponsor this week is
Mike that's moo plus oink moink m-y-n-k
Mike is working hard both to help save
the family farm and to get its customers
access to the highest quality meat on
Earth lamb chicken salmon and more for
instance fully 97 of the chicken served
in the U.S are dipped in chlorine but
the chicken you get from Mike is grown
on Family Farms and has never and will
never be dipped in chlorine
founded by an eighth generation farmer
moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
broken chicken and wild-cut Alaskan
salmon directly to your door this meat
is fantastic
Mike Farmers Farm like our grandparents
did and as a result Mike meat tastes
like it should which is to say delicious
not only that it's good for you like it
should be which is to say the animals
that the moike products are made from
eat while they're alive what they're
supposed to be eating so they continue
to be healthy for us to eat unlike much
farm raised
um meat and no doubt a lot happier
because of it true they are not
suffering illnesses from eating the
wrong stuff right exactly Mike gives you
total control over the quality and
source of your food you choose the meat
delivered in every box from rib eyes to
chicken breasts pork chops to salmon
fillets it's all fantastic and you can
cancel anytime
we love everything about Mike the fact
that the mat the mat
the meat it's meat it's grass-fed and
finished on small farms the lovely
Publications that come along with it and
of course the meat itself pork beef lamb
chickens it's all completely delicious
consider treating yourself or someone
else to some truly fabulous meat it's
grown humanely and with care and it's
fantastic for you and you'll never want
to go back
Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
Monk's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted I agree it's amazing keep
American farming going by signing up at
mikebox.com Darkhorse right now and
listeners of this show will receive free
filet mignon for a year that's one of
the best filet mignons you'll ever taste
that's one year of the best filet mignon
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
that's m-o-i-n-k box.com Dark Horse
that's moinkbox.com
Darkhorse so can you pronounce blank
properly for the uh no you can though I
can okay
[Music]
there it is all right yeah our final
sponsor and it's not that I'm shy I
actually can't make that point you have
to practice something I feel like I'm
gonna inhale my brain into my my nose
into my brains work it actually took me
years to get to being able to do the
lamb vocalization I that one was the
toughest for me but you've got to
practice the animal little baby baby
sheep or were you doing a full no I
guess it's full grown sheep yeah yeah
okay um but regardless yeah or as they
say in Boston irregardless
um yeah all right yeah final sponsor yes
no surprise to you this week is mind
Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in
at-home ketamine therapy offering a
combination of scientifically robust
medicine and clinically guided support
for people looking to improve their
mental health and well-being
if you or someone you love is struggling
with mental health issues they probably
learn large in your life there is no
one-size-fits-all solution but you know
that you or your loved one need
something that will help achieve a real
and Lasting breakthrough maybe it's time
for you to check out guided ketamine
Therapy Program from mind Bloom mind
Bloom could be your next and most
successful chapter in mental health and
well-being mind Bloom consists of
connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower cost
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin take mind Bloom's online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with a licensed clinician to determine
if mind Bloom is right for you if
approved you'll discuss your health
history and goals for mental health
treatment with your clinician to tailor
your mind Bloom regimen mind Bloom will
send you a kit in the mail complete with
medicine treatment materials and tips
for getting the most out of your
experience after only four sessions 89
percent of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements in their symptoms for
depression and anxiety reports one
client on their site quote I thought I
was broken now in the light now the
light inside me is growing stronger
every day let mind Bloom guide you
uh to a better chapter of mental health
and well-being right now mind Bloom is
offering our listeners 100 off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com Darkhorse and use
the promo code Darkhorse at checkout
go to mindbloom.com Dark Horse promo
code Darkhorse for 100 off your first
six session program today that's
m-i-n-d-b-l-o-oom.com slash Dark Horse
and use the promo code Darkhorse
all right that's our ads for the week
um we've got a lot of talk about
uh but I wanted to start with a couple
of of lighter things before we delve
into some of the the muck the muck yeah
first I have a correction and it's not
exactly a correction
um except it's a I made I
I mentioned Forrest Gump last week and I
said I hadn't seen the movie uh I think
we were talking about was
um
we're talking about whether or not there
were any roles out there acting roles
that were really ungendered where it
wouldn't really matter whether or not
you're male or female and I said I don't
know I haven't seen it maybe before I
scump well I just apparently so wrong
and um and this prompted some discussion
online about whether or not it is in
fact one of the greatest movies ever or
some people are like it's totally
overrated and either way I think we
clearly need to see it
um but it it reminded it reminded me of
why one should not say I mean at least I
was careful I said I haven't seen it but
maybe this but it's just really really
ridiculously wrong to imagine that that
was a character that was ungendered
um but then in the sort of in the wake
of that conversation a friend of ours
pointed out that there is a production
of Samuel Beckett's Waiting for Godot uh
that is being that has been canceled
because as Beckett so this is the
classic awesome awesome freaking play
um from sort of uh theater of the Absurd
uh genre
and uh and
Beckett who is now dead uh required that
the characters was basically just two
characters there are a couple other
really bit players but it's uh it's uh
Vladimir and astragon I want to say yeah
um I want Pozo
um that they beat male and
I don't know when I first heard I was
like oh I guess maybe
um uh but whatever it was Becca was the
playwright and he said it has to be male
and he's gone now and I think it's his
son who uh oversees his estate and there
was some
um some play being done some production
of Godot being done in which many of the
people behind the scenes many of the
people who were not on the stage were
actually female and there was no
injunction against that but they were
abiding by Beckett's rules that the
actors the characters are male and they
actually be played by male actors and it
was shut down because this is somehow
non-equitable right none non-equitable
not fair not not okay because we we need
to be present in everything no matter
what and you know there's a we're not
this is not the story that we want to
spend a lot of time talking about today
but
my God people
like
seriously not everyone gets to show up
in every place at every moment the idea
that
women need to be allowed to be playing
characters that were written as male
characters
in a play in which the playwright said
these are actually male characters and
they need to be played by male
characters
is a little bit like and I will probably
take some for this but a little bit
like men who are dressed up as women
claiming that they need to be allowed
into women's music festivals or women's
domestic crisis centers or women's
sports right like nope actually there's
rules
and sometimes the rules aren't what you
like and
um you're gonna have to deal with that
yeah I mean it
invalidates the entire purpose of the
exercise right it makes which this the
the the playwright or the or the or the
the uh
desire to impose rules on any given play
that require openness to people of
configurations you know there are no
children in the play right
no one in a wheelchair in the play right
um
this is an a it's the perfect example of
sophistry yes right because the whole
point of the play is to actually say
something or in Beckett's case in a
strange way not to say something but to
explore and to explore the nature of
waiting and infinity and expectation and
hope and humanity and you know all of
these things it's not about
simultaneously a tiny play in terms of
like what happens yeah and the scope of
space that is traveled and enormous it's
like it's infinite it's in its
implications and
sorry I interrupt you but I feel like I
haven't gone back and reread it but you
know this is what I'm I love this play
yeah I have it you know I actually have
two copies of it I found it also in
another
um anthology of plays on our Shelf here
um it feels to me like it's explicitly
a non-sexual play right and so I think
that you know it's not mine to say but I
think that Godot would work if it were
all female well but I and you know okay
yes and you know there's homosexual
attraction I don't care right like I
think given that most of the world is
heterosexual and given that once you
have mixed sex groups interacting in a
very sparse place you raise this
question of like oh well what did that
mean what was that about was that was
that interest what like what is going on
there and so this like saying like no
you know what it's all male and I think
you could equally well say no it's all
female except I didn't write the play so
I don't get to say that but I think that
this would work equally well as it just
like you know what it's just going to be
all one thing so that we don't raise the
question so that issue is not Central to
the play yes but so first off
I think it is perfectly within bounds
for Becca to say this should be staged
as
males only totally I think it is
perfectly valid for somebody who wishes
to Stage the play to say I know what the
play writes wishes were but uh it's not
his to say I'm going to Stage IT female
or I'm going to Stage IT mix sex I
wouldn't I wouldn't apparently the
estate doesn't let that happen
apparently it's still somehow I don't
know the rules they're illegal there are
legal bits but at the moment that this
becomes public domain because it's
existed too long I I would not fault
anybody for violating the playwright's
wishes but I do think it ought to be you
ought to do that consciously you ought
to say here's why right here's here's
why I'm doing that and the show notes
should say you know if you have flaunted
those things totally legally then you
need then you should acknowledge that
but that's all in the
um in the the scope I will point out
there is one section of the play that I
recall that would have to be refigured
for female characters okay if I am
remembering correctly
hope I have this correct but yeah I
probably haven't read it since high
school but
um there's a point at which the futility
of waiting for Godot causes the
characters to toy with the idea of of
suicide by hanging and one of the
arguments in favor is that it will give
them erections if I remember correct I
think that does
it am I wrong I I also did not go back
but uh I think it's in there and I'm not
going to be able to find it quickly and
you know look I'm I'm uh totally open as
we I think talked about last week to
re-figuring of things like plays where
you know Romeo and Juliet is radically
refigured in West Side Story for example
yep and so I'm up for a radical
re-figuring of this and it would be
interesting to have females have that
discussion and then realize that in fact
that was not an argument in favor
because of course it wouldn't work
right you could do that so anyway
it's all it's all available for the
refiguring but nonetheless the idea that
the play is invalid because it is
inherently about males is preposterous
some things are totally Preposterous yep
okay so there's that and there's one
other thing I want to uh talk about
before before we get into the main main
meet here which I said last week that we
would talk about dogs a little bit and
we never got to dogs
and this was prompted by you know not
last week but
two weeks ago now I was in Portland for
a few days and hanging in coffee shops
and watching people and um and also
walking walking around various
neighborhoods watching people
and I had the thought as I did
multiple times when we lived in Portland
uh and you know less so now that we're
on an island without as many without as
much Commerce without as many
opportunity to sort of run into into
people and to do people watching without
it being really obvious that you're
being watched
um
I had the thought
dogs may be the ones to save us dogs May
save
the world uh in so far as
they break down the borders between
people and it's easier if both strangers
to one another have dogs because the
dogs don't care
and uh you know increasingly there are
people who are like oh no no don't you
know well my dog doesn't get along with
it like okay well you know I wish she
had taught your dog to be a dog then and
like I know that some dogs really can't
can't do this thing with other dogs but
that's not very dog-ish of them but in
general dogs are curious about other
dogs dogs are also curious about other
people but people tend to be interested
in dogs and dogs are definitely
interested in dogs and whereas people
especially in cities are quite happy to
walk by each other and either pretend
the other person doesn't exist or often
just sort of stare at them or you know
make a scowl or something you know how
dare you smile at me once the dog has uh
once they've gone up to each other and
investigate each other either nose to
nose or nose to butt or you know all the
various configurations by which dogs
greet each other
the people especially if the dogs are
leashed and are therefore sort of pulled
into Closer Closer proximity
have a much harder time being Grim with
one another
they just have a much much more
difficult time
and
this does this is true regardless of you
know whether or not you're one of those
rare people who actually doesn't like
dogs
um and I'm not saying like oh cat people
like
I sort of think of myself as a cat
person more than a dog person but come
on dogs right like it's dogs the one
thing we can all agree on yeah something
with you we've got as you you've pointed
out uh what something like and you know
there's a there's a lot of different
ways in and there's some competing uh
hypotheses out there yet but something
like well many tens of thousands of
years of co-evolution with dogs and uh
really what that means is that we have
co-evolved with them
they have you know we oh yeah we
domesticated dogs dogs are you know our
longest uh domesticate yeah but you know
we have co-evolved with dogs and uh they
are showing us
they're reminding us if we let them as
we watch the ways that dogs interact
with each other on the street and with
with with the owners uh how to be our
best selves and if we can if we can
listen to them and watch them and
interact a little bit more like they do
we might find a way out a little bit
more quickly yeah dogs I I love this
point of yours and I I quite agree with
it I've seen the online version of this
where people put aside their differences
uh to remark on yeah very often dogs and
their interesting Behavior I do think
it's interesting uh you know we all know
examples of dogs
you know who picked up their owner's
racism or whatever yeah right right that
used to happen much more I believe
because I think racism went out of
fashion and you know it's back hopefully
the dogs will not pick it up this time
but
um but there is something dogs are
something like three times as long under
our our uh under our mutualism as our
next closest domesticate because their
domestication had nothing to do with
farming whereas everything else is post
farming dogs are older in the human
lineage than rice
by far Yeah by far yeah about three
times as you say but the there is
something you know you no owner controls
what their dog thinks of some other dog
dogs have their own thoughts
into an interaction in which the nature
of the human beings and even the other
dog is you know that is beyond yours to
say anything about and
um you know I love the idea that dogs
might remind us of our more ancient
selves remind us how much is at stake
and how lucky we are to even be here you
know what did the last thirty thousand
years look like that we should arrive at
this moment where we do have uh enough
control over the natural world that we
can you know dedicate ourselves to
abstractions and the creation of Art and
beauty and all of these things because
more or less we have the basics taken
care of and why we would toy with
wrecking that right why we wouldn't be
obsessed with preserving what we've
accomplished so that we can actually
move forward rather than have it all
detonate out from under us
um you know a dog is a pretty good
reminder of that if you if you tune into
it correctly yeah very much so
okay
um
did you want to start
actually could we finish there I'm happy
either way but uh do you want me to
start there
I thought so but um
you want to start by talking about this
then sure okay
so
the New York Times
you remember the New York Times I recall
them yes we do you know that we still
subscribe to the New York Times
I know this is a thorn in your side and
you know we don't we we can no longer
get um uh paper delivery here on the
island so um and by the time it gets
here it's so soft
but we're still we're sorry
foolish
but you know no I I try to read widely
and
um we had been subscribers to the New
York Times since we were in college and
uh
and we are still
um back when we were in college I don't
remember ever being mentioned in the New
York Times you ever been mentioned in
the New York Times I don't think I don't
think it happened yeah
yeah well um
that changed yes yes okay so you can
show my screen here Zach uh we're gonna
go back and forth a few times here this
week uh sorry this is from February 9th
so what is that two days ago Steve
bannon's podcast is top misinformation
spreader study says
it's large podcast study found that Mr
bannon's war room had more falsehoods
and unsubstantiated claims than other
political talk shows
and they've got an uh an attractive
picture of Steve Bannon because of
course they do because of of course
that's what they do here
um
so uh you're maybe giving ice cream back
here so I can
so I can talk a little bit about this
actually what we'll do here is the uh
yeah you can show my screen well briefly
again this is again from the same New
York Times article
Steve Bennett's War Room podcast topped
The Brookings institutions list of
political talk shows airing false
misleading and unsubstantiated claims
they've got
um they looked at a lot of a lot of
podcasts in the top 10 sources of
misinformation where
um War Room the Charlie Kirk show The
Rush Limbaugh Show the Michael Savage
show and Brett Weinstein Dark Horse
podcast my God
remarkable yeah and it's remarkable
remarkable okay so um
what the actual I mean really
that's like that's a that's about where
where I land but
um this is based on a uh
report from
The Brookings Institute okay and you
know did not show my screen yet Zachary
uh
I lost
the section that I was at unfortunately
um
Brookings which is a a think tank uh did
this research
on podcasts and their content
and they call this research audible
Reckoning how top of political
podcasters spread unsubstantiated and
false claims
and they say for instance
uh that
go on so let me just say when I first
encountered this a friend alerted me to
the fact that um that we had been
mentioned in the times uh in this regard
was unaware of it and I went looking and
oh it's the Brookings institution has
done a study
and my immediate reaction was well I
know where the bodies are buried because
in order to make such an assessment you
would need a method and no method is
actually conceivable here there's no
method you could justify because what
they're claiming to assess is the
veracity of claims made but what they
are going to be talking about are claims
in which what is true is in contention
well and this so this is exactly what I
was just trying to find which I had set
up but it disappeared on me but you can
now show Zachary
um this is you know cataloging
unsubstantiated and false claims how'd
they do it what was their method
reading from the brookness institution
Research In addition to systematically
limiting the podcast series examinants
analysis it was also important to
restrict the number of unsubstantiated
and false claims searched for across
podcast episode transcripts Casino
there's just so many to do this the
research relied on claims compiled in
two different ways
next was the text of claims or
statements fact checked as false by
either PolitiFact or Snopes two
independent fact-checking organizations
whose fact checks are widely relied upon
by the public and members of the media
and Academia as credible and well
substantiated
are they
now
my very first Natural Selections piece
which I called fact Checkers aren't
scientists went through at that point
that was in
um July of 2021.
went through a number of things that
PolitiFact had claimed were not just
wrong but egregious they their their
rating system goes from like totally
true to literally they call it liar liar
pants on fire they called a couple of
the things that you had claimed or Dr
Malone had claimed in the podcast that
you did with Dr Malone and Steve Kirsch
as liar liar pants on fire level wrong
which then
months later
at the point that someone had decided to
actually reconcile the facts with the
facts went oops not only not wrong or
egregious but actually right they just
quietly silently switched it
and didn't say anything no public
Reckoning no nothing nothing right so
PolitiFact Is Brookings says
widely relied upon by the public and
members of the media and Academia as
credible and well substantiated yeah as
of the CDC as is the FDA as is the who
like as are all of these institutions
which time and time and time again
during the pandemic have by us and some
other people
been effectively checked using what
using the tools of science
and
um
my God uh so let's just show a couple
more things here this is figure 12 from
the brook news report unsubstantiated or
false claims about alternative
treatments and prevention were more
common than all other categories
combined
there we go uh so they found uh that you
know even conspiracies
I don't even know what that is right
like conspiracies
um showed up almost uh you know a
quarter a quarter of the time as
discussion of alternative treatments to
prevention or you know vaccine efficacy
and side effects disease severity
government policy response testing now
it was alternative treatments and
prevention that was the biggest source
of misinformation apparently during the
covet for during the coverage yeah let's
do that during the covid
um by podcasters who are you know waving
around their credentials like us
and
which ones are those again now you
talked about someone this last week and
we talked about this a lot over the last
several years but uh things like oh yes
the Voldemort of alternative treatments
Ivermectin which
does work and is safe
and still I'm finding pieces in the New
York Times claiming that it's not only
not effective
but not safe
this is a drug that's been on the list
the whose list of essential medicines
for a long time
if it weren't safe it wouldn't be there
it is safe
it has been demonstrated over and over
and over again to be effective the first
moment that we started talking about it
we already knew it was safe
it's effective seemed probably so maybe
even unsure
the evidence has just gotten stronger
and stronger and stronger and this
discussion right now
is going to increase our ranking in a
future piece of research by The
Brookings institution in terms of the
amount of misinformation that we are
engaging in so let us agree that the
structure here is for let's work
backwards you've got a news report
saying okay we've got a misinformation
problem that news report is based on
Research okay research the research was
done by the Brookings institution oh the
research had a method the method
involved looking up on Snopes and
PolitiFact nakedly political right yep
Snopes may not have been at the
beginning but now nakedly political
and so the point is at you're reading
the New York Times and you're seeing
that in fact there's a misinformation
problem and if you chase it all the way
back to how you would know
there's no they're there now I do
remember and I stared at it for a goodly
long time because I of course when I
looked at it I'm like look they've just
described that they've done research for
which no conceivable method could exist
so I'm going to go look at the method
and I'm my prediction is there won't be
one that is in any remote way valid
because there can't be right so okay
PolitiFact and Snopes let's call me
right there was no method and then they
invoke some mysterious dictionary that
has terminology that would tell you they
might as well invoke a crystal ball
right this is just simple you know it's
really they're the ones claiming the
mantle of science a text that no one's
allowed to see is the Arbiter of truth
right and so the point is look you can
even do science on what they're doing
right oh here's a claim I bet it's
garbage prediction there won't be a
method let's go look at the method
because they claim there is one oh it's
looking stuff up on PolitiFact and
Snopes and some dictionary they don't
share ah no method as predicted right
science even works on this stuff right
yeah it's
not not that they would know not that
they well they don't care I also think
they don't know I think I think that's I
think that's part of what's going on I
think that's part of why you know part
of what we did in the classroom for 15
years and part of what we've been doing
in the podcast is saying you know what
you can science the stuff you can apply
scientific thinking scientific rigor
scientific Logic the scientific method
uh to any claim and you may not have the
tools with which to assess the claim but
you can figure out what you would need
to know in order to assess it and you
can figure out what can't possibly be
true when you can figure out what the
assumptions are of the people making the
claim etc etc and that is what we are
doing and we are sharing it with other
people so that you all can begin to
employ the same kinds of tools and
assess things for yourselves and what
the mainstream media what the think
tanks and the mainstream media who are
trying their hardest to maintain the
status quo are doing is saying don't
look at that that's this is dangerous
over there those those people who are
talking
is bad it's well it's it's bad stuff
what they're doing it's
the exact flaw is pseudo quantification
right what they want to do is claim that
they made a ranking a numerical ranking
right so what they've done is they have
created the impression that there is
something to be counted and what they
did is simply counted and here's the
structure it's as objective as can be I
mean look we've got a bar graph right we
didn't and we it's not like we took
those are digits on it yeah we asked a
spreadsheet to make a bar graph and it
just simply took the number in the cell
and translated into a Distance on the
screen right and the point is yes but
you you got it from Snopes it's
snow right so oh my God and worse worse
you know I kept digging in this thing
and it's not like I read it but hold on
the other thing I noticed right it
didn't take long to run across the fact
that this is somehow borrowing from data
and Society you remember data and
Society here's my recollection of data
and Society back in the early days of
the so-called IDW data and Society
reported that the IDW was was Far Right
their term now the funny thing was that
a lot of us looked at this and said wait
a second of the named people in the IDW
more than half are left wing what that
means is that this report well and
somewhere in here and I'm not finding at
the moment they rank a bunch of podcasts
in terms of their political leanings and
they have us as conservative they have
us as well but that's just the point so
the report itself is guilty of egregious
misinformation it is guilty of
partnering with people who have a
history of spreading misinformation
about us none of this is apparently of a
concern though in Brookings institution
because their real purpose is a bar
graph that makes it look as if something
countable makes us uh unreliable which
is of course not true right this is
really a question of keeping people
um inside of a mental prison yes the
point is what they don't want is for you
to start listening to voices who have
been correct about things and the reason
that you're not going to listen to them
is because as you are told that actually
this person got this right you will read
oh no they get things wrong all the time
it must be a rare case of them being
right
etcetera nonsense right it's the same
attack as uh calling us gurus right the
idea is oh if you listen to them you're
a sucker right oh if you listen to the
Dark Horse podcast uh you are absorbing
misinformation and if you don't know
that that's because you haven't done the
hard work of uh going to Snopes or
whatever right I mean it couldn't be
more muppety this is this is this is
childish right if a college student came
up with a method this bad you would sit
them down and you would gently say I
understand what you're trying to do
here's why that doesn't work right so
yes and uh at risk of getting into like
the weeds that was Evergreen uh we gave
students took full-time programs 16
credit programs and you gave them
narrative evaluations and you you could
and sometimes in order to apply to grad
school and such there was a method by
which you could turn those narrative
evaluations into grids so that they
could calculate a GPA but there weren't
grades but what that meant was that if a
student did some did fail to do any work
at all or the work was so absurdly
missing
anything of value
what you did what I did was uh you know
with with compassion
with full respect for the human on the
other side of the interaction would say
I'm not writing you in every a narrative
evaluation for this part of the program
you just don't get any credit at all
this disappears from your record and
that's a gift you should go back to zero
and start over because this thing
isn't any good it's terrible it's
terrible and so the point is in college
you might write a report
the purpose of the report you write in
college is not to make it into the world
and inform people about things it's to
train you to write a report that
actually has some content in it here's a
bunch of people who should have failed
at the college level and either gone
back and learned how to do this properly
or they shouldn't be doing it at all in
public because they don't understand how
to do it now the real question is
is there actually an intent inside the
Brookings institution or data and
Society or the New York Times to
actually report things that are real and
are they it up this badly or is
that not the point is the point pure
politics is the point to keep people
subscribed to the same bad uh
compromised channels of information
because the idea is to feed them bad
information in the future and you can't
do that if they have an alternative
here's an extended quote from the
Brookings Institute research
foreign
yet apart from these conspiracy theories
unsubstantiated or false claims shared
at this time were far more nuanced and
primarily involved wait for it
misunderstandings of science
yeah it's quite a client several
prominent podcasters carved out
positions of authority during this
period of high uncertainty for example
Heather high and Brett Weinstein that's
us relied on their backgrounds in
evolutionary biology to amass a white
audience for their unconventional
coronavirus advice the pair repeated
unproven claims about the prophylactic
use of various treatments including
Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine and
cast doubt on vaccine safety
throughout their episodes high in
Weinstein tried to bolster perceptions
of their credentials by using technical
terms
in one episode Weinstein offered a
little brain teaser saying that quote
correlation is in fact evidence of
causation if there was a causal
hypothesis pre-existing the observation
of the correlation end quote
I can't even read this next part with a
straight face while it's unclear exactly
what he is referencing
perhaps the most basic tentative
statistics emphasizes that correlation
does not equal causation isn't is indeed
susceptible to confounders
although researchers can control for
potential known confounders there may be
infinitely more unknown confounding
variables driving any absurd
relationship rather than protecting
researchers against confounding a
pre-existing hypothesis may instead make
them more prone to confirmation bias
Weinstein however may have deployed this
language to appear to burnish the
scientific Bona fides of the host for a
non-technical audience
you know who's trying to burnish your
scientific Bona fides for the benefit of
a non-technical audience that's you
Brookings Institute and the New York
Times and all the rest of you you
clearly have no idea what you're doing
you don't understand what a hypothesis
is and that prediction
changes
Baseline oh my God this is so bad okay
I'm sorry like let me just finish read
like this is so bad okay go on they have
it's so bad invalidated most of Science
in their claim because what they've done
is ruled out the possibility that you
could test an idea by making a
prediction and then seeing whether the
correlation exists if this is true you
can't know anything ever there is no
knowledge there's no basis to know
anything what's more the very things
that they are claiming that we the most
basic tentative statistics right but
with so this is a classic this is a
classic
um mid-wit idiocy yeah right because the
point is
um you come to a level of understanding
which is correlation does not imply
causation which is shorthand for
correlation alone does not imply
causation our brain teaser was yes it
does imply causation when you
hypothesize that there would be a
correlation the evidence is all the
stronger if it is an unexpected
correlation predicted only by that
hypothesis and then lo and behold you
find it and so the point is these people
are non-scientists
misunderstanding what actual science is
and deploying this syllogism without an
understanding of what it even means and
if I mean I guess you I will finish the
rest of this in a minute it's like you
can take this off the screen for the
moment
um if
if the author of this report
is willing to say
I don't even know what this means
but we all know don't we the correlation
of some black causation
why is it that we are supposed to take
anything that this person says or that
the people who rely on this kind of
analysis
with any kind of seriousness like this
is a demonstration of a failure to
understand
basic scientific logic right that's so
basically the most fundamental the most
fun which is that we we you know your
observation of a pattern is not a
scientific conclusion you have to get to
a hypothesis about what might cause the
pattern then you have to test that with
a prediction right that's how you
discover this thing and so even well
there's your own report should collapse
under this because the whole idea that
anybody knows what's true about covid
and therefore that we can say that those
other things must be false that comes
from work in which people have deployed
a hypothesis and then look for a
correlation
to be fair to these people which I think
were being very very fair but um they're
not alone
I remember back when we were professors
and I would get asked to peer review
papers
for journals because this is an
expectation this is part of the unpaid
work of being
a professors that you get asked to peer
review papers for various journals and
the the most frequent
reason that I gave to reject a paper
was
there's no hypothesis
the authors want to reframe this as
we collected a bunch of information and
from that made an observation and now we
have a hypothesis but it's not been
tested
then they could rework what they've
submitted but in general scientific
journals don't like to publish things
that don't claim to have results
if you didn't have a predictive
hypothesis in the first place then what
you've collected aren't data they're not
a test of anything
and the fact that many people who are
purportedly doing science don't
understand the distinction means that
some person at the Brookings Institute
with a PhD in something political
doesn't understand it maybe isn't that
surprising but it's going to destroy the
planet like you know this this level of
of
the combination of like deviousness and
ignorance is
devastating to discourse and to our
sense making like we cannot hope to make
our way through a landscape of lots of
different kinds of information coming at
us if we can't put a couple of simple
things in order and say I made an
observation
what are all the possible reasons that
thing could be true
okay I've got three possibilities
if possibility a let's call it a
hypothesis we're true what else would
necessarily be true that's prediction
that follows from hypothesis a same for
prediction that follows from hypothesis
B and C okay are these mutually
exclusive super easy and wonderful if
they are if they're not well the
predictions from A and B aren't really
exclusive but if C is if the prediction
from C is true then we've definitely
excluded those two and if one of these
is true we're still stuck with these two
and on and on it goes right
the
it's not that hard
School
kills this in US
and apparently higher ed and the
credentials that most of these people
are walking around with completely
obliterates the ability to Think Through
basic logic you have something yeah I've
got a couple things yeah one one of the
things that we have done
in the beginning on Dark Horse is build
up people's scientific toolkit with
principles that we rely on I don't claim
that they're necessarily finished but
there are a couple principles that that
belong here one principle is every
scientific paper
would describe its relationship to a
hypothesis and the relationship really
comes down to one of two things
either it's an observation which leads
to a hypothesis which then needs a test
or it is a test of a hypothesis that
exists now part of the problem as we've
talked about is that this is all on the
honor System and one of the way for
people who are pursuing a credential or
grant money to cheat is to pretend that
some observation they've made was
actually a test of a hypothesis that
they only came up with after oh look
what my data showed Oh I totally thought
that all along yeah yeah this was a test
of that thing that it's now shown to be
true so the honor System is a problem
here but when done properly you're doing
one of there's nothing wrong with not
having a pre-existing hypothesis but the
point is that says you're on step one
you're on the observation phase that's
right if you have observed and then you
want to go run a test you need a
hypothesis and you need to have that you
cannot test it with the observations
you've already made you could go back to
a data set and you could look for some
other pattern that you've now predicted
will exist there but you have to
actually run a new test otherwise it's
scientifically invalid right so anyway
that's the process that I can go back to
your own data set like you can look at
other people's data
um and say you know you could query your
data set for something else you can't
query it for the observation that set
the process in motion you could look for
something else that you didn't know was
there or not there you could look for
some other correlation but the
clearly these people do not understand
the basics of how science works and it's
not you know children do scientific
thinking without having to be trained
they don't do it perfectly they don't do
it in a paparian way they're not
falsificationists but the point is
scientific thinking is natural and as
you say it's drummed out of us by bad
education but these people clearly
either don't know or don't care or both
right
the second piece of uh the toolkit I
want to point out somewhere in what you
read they do what Scott Adams calls mind
reading where they say that the reason
that we have used technical terms which
they don't understand Weinstein however
may have deployed this language to
appear to burnish the scientific Bona
fides of the hosts for a non-technical
audience is that the sentence you're
after yes first of all for a bunch of
Humanity's morons that's not even good
English right
read it again
Weinstein however may have deployed this
language to appear to burnish the
scientific Bona fides of the hosts for a
non-technical audience appear to burnish
what they mean is burnish appeared to
burnish is the Revelation
right so you're not even doing Humanity
as well and it's you know that's a
pretty low bar but yeah
um okay here's the point
what are the chances that that
accusation would land on a podcast that
has the following thing as a piece of
toolkit which we have deployed and tried
to teach our audience repeatedly what's
happening the distinction between jargon
and terms of art yeah yeah now what we
say is that terms of art are a necessary
evil if you're working on something
technical you will probably need some
terms that are not straightforward this
should be minimized you want as few of
those things as possible you want them
as straightforward as possible but if
you're working on technical material
it's probably not going to be zero
you're going to have to make some terms
that are technical that need to be
described explicitly
jargon is the abuse of the fact that you
might need technical terms to do
technical work to keep people out to
keep them from knowing what you're
talking about it is the use of
unnecessarily complex language in order
to limit the discussion to only insiders
right that is not a necessary evil
that's just simply an evil so the idea
that they're going to accuse us of using
language just like correlation right
yeah exactly hypothesis yeah that's
definitely us using jargon there all
right so I I do have to confess that as
you were talking I thought I did just
use the word synapomorphy during an ad
read for shoes but I did Define the term
yes yes you did Define yes exactly
um yes and appomorphia is one of those
things it's it's a necessary well it's
not a it's not an immediately intuitive
term but since we're no longer in the ad
read and I've just used it again a
synapomorphy is a shared derived
characteristic for a particular clade so
hair or fur is a snap morphe for mammals
and that doesn't mean that we all have
them because you can lose them but it's
diagnostic for the group it means that
it accompanies the evolution of the
group and it didn't exist uh in the
group from which the group descended it
doesn't exist in pretty mammal ancestors
yes four chambered heart also a snap
morphe of mammals anyway the diaphragm
yeah
um okay so anyway
I think first of all um let's just be
honest
uh
if the question was we have been of
course yeah no but I'm just saying like
honest let's let's can we
hold that thought
I would like to take this opportunity to
invite the staff at the Brokenness
Institute in the New York Times and all
the rest of you guys
to be honest
let's be honest start now yeah start it
would be good yeah I would be I would be
less resentful of our New York Times
subscription that you started being
honest now yeah
um
let us be honest about the score here
okay at a logical level this is
as stupid as a report could be it is an
exercise in pseudo quantification it is
hilarious that when you get to the
methods you find Snopes PolitiFact in
some dictionary that they don't share
right that is not a method that's
garbage yeah okay they still win that's
the problem yeah yeah because most
people will be scared away from podcasts
like this one by the implication that
somebody has done a scientific study and
decided that we are saying untrue things
so this is absolutely cheating what
they're doing is instead of pointing to
a thing you know the spike protein made
by the uh the vaccines is cytotoxic
right that is a factual claim that I
made or Robert Malone made I can't
remember which one of us made it in this
podcast
we were back checked I think by
PolitiFact who said that's false and
then it turned out to be true of course
because logically speaking it makes
sense that because the spike protein of
the coronavirus is cytotoxic and the
spike protein made by the vaccines is
much more like that Spike protein than
it is different and there's no reason to
think its differences render it
non-toxic right it was a logical thing
to say but the point is they don't want
to have that discussion because they
will lose right where we have gotten
stuff wrong we have corrected it it's
not a win for them there's no accusation
to be leveled what they want to do
instead is pretend that actually there
is a volume of information that they
have gone through it and they have
discovered a pattern of being factually
incorrect without having so hard right
now the funny thing is that we actually
had you at one point on our podcast
uh said that we needed better Skeptics
folks decided to take up that challenge
and they actually went through
transcripts of our podcasts they
solicited from our critics indicators of
where in those transcripts we had said
something that was incorrect and then
they went and evaluated those claims and
they did not find this pattern they
found a few very minor places but in
general they found that all the things
that people were saying were false were
not in fact false right so if done uh by
some reasonable method it comes out
entirely differently but the real point
is the bar graph the impermeature on the
New York Times the imprimature on the
Brookings institution all of those
things are designed
um to scare people away from things that
they have no mechanism for directly
challenging yep
um
a couple more things from this
um just
the same section that I was just reading
from in the Brookings Institute thing
you don't need to show my screen here
Zach
some podcasters also cited
non-peer-reviewed preprints and data
which often contained faulty statistical
analysis or poor research designs to
bolster their prior beliefs on the
efficacy of ivermectin for instance
while some merrily dismissing similar
non-peer-reviewed studies whose
conclusions ran contrary to their
preferences
uh I read that and then by chance
um because uh I get
Nature and Science into my inbox
whenever they put out a new issue uh I I
saw this which you can show
my screen now this from nature this week
this is nature news so your nature is
one of the two uh most prominent science
journals in the world and they also have
a basically a new section so it's a
great source for uh Science News Cova
drug drives viral mutations and now some
won't want to Halt its use analysis
reveals the signature of the antiviral
drug monopurovir and SARS cov2 sequences
riddled with mutations
so there's a lot to talk about there and
I don't know that we're going to talk
about most of it right now but I just
want to point out that nature
um which is not a right wing political
podcast riddle with misinformation is
that what we are nature's not I think we
can all agree
um this is
um this study was post what this study
was posted on the med rxiv preprint
server in January it is not yet been
peer-reviewed but why is nature talking
about it then goodness there's probably
statistical errors in there that the
peers would certainly have discovered
because the peers definitely know the
difference between uh
right causation correlation which of
course
um
pretends that the effect of peer review
is to vastly increase the quality of
what is published and that is actually a
testable hypothesis I'm trying to
remember somebody wrote a very good I
believe it was a sub stack evaluating
peer reviews effectiveness at this very
thing I read it a couple weeks ago I
will attempt to dig it up assuming I can
find it we will put it in the in the
notes of this podcast but the point is
peer review is actually a failure in
this regard and we acknowledged at the
point that we talked about many things
on the preprint servers that that does
increase the amount of noise however
what it means is that you don't have all
of the skullduggery that takes place in
the so-called peer review process
interfering with your ability to know
what's going on you basically have a raw
scientific discussion and you have to
sort wheat from chaff which is what we
do and that's yeah part of what we did
from the beginning now we've talked
about peer review many many times on
this podcast including very early on in
our discussion back in like March or
April 2020
uh you know it the idea sounds brilliant
it's not inherent to the scientific
process at all
um what is is uh opening up your ideas
to be challenged by friend info like
that that is an important part of the
scientific process but peer review is
not peer review is basically a modern
invention to deal with the fact that we
you know there's a lot of people trying
to do science now and trying to get the
attention of you know being a larger
number of people
um
but uh peer review itself it actually
acts more like a gated community now
and like an actual ability to to sort
wheat from chat you know I mentioned
earlier that I used to do peer review uh
and uh very often when I would say you
know sort of the things that you can
recommend are like this is awesome no
change is necessary uh this is really
good but there's a couple things you
know I'd like to know more about what
this analysis was you know they need to
look at the literature over here this
that and the other
um you know or recommend to uh to
project those are you know usually more
categories than that but this is sort of
the three categories that is a peer
review you're you're offered uh to
recommend for a paper and uh very rarely
when I said recommend to reject on
account of there's no hypothesis but
they're pretending there was uh was the
paper actually rejected because you know
peer review is often done as sort of
like a majority vote it's like okay with
the editor is going to send this out to
three possible peer reviewers and
they're going to come back and if I'm
the only one who gives a damn about
they're not being a hypothesis uh then
the paper is not going to be rejected
and it's going to you know go into
literature yeah it's a very it's a very
arbitrary filter yeah uh that often
introduces errors it sends authors back
to do things that are unnecessary it you
know and the the differences between the
pure the peer of yours is it's it's
funny like this it's its own it's its
own literature it's a completely broken
process that has really no purpose right
it's really a holdover from a time in
which there was a limit to the amount of
stuff that you could publish because ink
and paper were expensive and so that
space had a value yep
um and the fact is this stuff is now
electronically published why should
anyone be in a position to stop you from
publishing a piece of work because it's
bad if it's bad it doesn't stand up but
if it's great and somebody said it was
bad because they were your competitor
and they didn't want to see the light of
day why should that have any weight at
all well so you know if I'm if I'm in a
steel man you know why journals why
editors right there's too much
information uh and we all have to
we all have to figure out some ways to
funnel our attention to ex you know to
exclude some of the things that want our
attention so that we can focus on this
and I've told this story before too but
you know we we are generalists we have
done very you know very focused highly
specialized work in a number of Demands
but we are more or less generalists as
in general is uh the approach to
understanding life that is evolutionary
biology
but I remember the you know two-day
interview that I had when I was applying
for the job at Evergreen
I had an hour free between all the
different interviews and such and I went
to the library and the library was
pretty bad it was very bad I was a
little you know a Podunk Library without
very many journals at all and this would
have been in 2000 two I guess
and so there wasn't as much available
online and I went to one of the faculty
on the committee that was deciding
whether or not to hire me and said how
do you how do you do your work here I
don't like I don't I don't see how you
can do your work when this is the
library you have access to and this
person who I respect greatly said oh I
subscribed to the three journals I need
and that's it that's all I need
I thought well but I don't just I don't
even know which three journals I would
choose I mean I
probably name three do you really tell
me you can only look at three scientific
journals ever for the rest of your life
I'd pick three but they certainly
wouldn't be like you know in this
particular little field it doesn't let
you do generalist work it doesn't let
you to do generous work and you know
especially given that nature and science
like all the journals are now so much
crappier than they used to be and not
honoring you know good science at all uh
you know the idea that oh I just I look
at the thing that I need to look at that
I'm interested in now like even if that
is good for you now because the
particular research program you're doing
now for the next six months or a year
really does take you into that space
how about letting your mind expand and
go into an adjacent space an adjacent
space and over here and over here and
over here and you know that is one of
the things that the internet has allowed
that you don't need access to the
Library of Alexandria or whatever it's
modern uh Counterpoint is you can say oh
oh okay and this you know this is
actually some of the work that I did for
Bob trivers back when I was his research
assistant as an undergrad before you
know
the early 90s you know he'd be he'd read
a paper and be like oh wow what oh I
want to see these references go get them
it was a generalist well who's a
generalist still is right
um and he'd say you know this is this is
my job for him like I would run back and
forth between his office and the library
and get the references and photocopy
them and bring them back and you've
quickly sounded like oh this reference
and go back and now you can do that
without having to hire a research
assistant right so and it was amazing
and
if you really are only saying oh I'm
only interested in these little things
here well you're not going to be able to
see the bigger picture and therefore you
are inherently going to be missing at
least some of what is true and maybe all
of it
a couple points one
the reason though there has been a
dramatic narrowing of focus graduate
school Narrows you to focus on a
question so small that you can't get
scooped because you're the only expert
or there's one or two others and you
know what they're working on right yeah
and it's a terrible process from the
point of view of getting the most bang
for the buck out of science you want
people as generalists a they make much
better teachers right if you want to
teach the Next Generation how to think
and what's true you don't want somebody
who trained very narrowly you want
somebody trained broadly but B the
Innovations of a generalist are likely
to be much more consequential right the
point is they're not some narrowly
focused thing which yes maybe you know
there's some cure for cancer lurking in
your narrow little realm but probably
not right if you're going to find some
general principle that is actually going
to level up a bunch of different
disciplines it's going to be a
generalist who finds it the second thing
is
um you you bristled a little bit at my
claim that whose wife should peers be
able to stop you from publishing your
thing just because they say it's bad the
fact is maybe I just said I can defend
why editors and journals exist oh I'm
not arguing that editors in journal
shouldn't exist maybe they should I
think by and large they're terrible
they're not the only thing that should
exist but the point is that should be no
bar to your putting your work somewhere
where it can be of value if it takes 500
years for your work to turn out to have
been prescient right the fact that
people were wrong for 499 years after
you did it is not an argument against
people reading it that's in fact they
should be able to go back and find out
you know this person was dismissed at
the time turns out they were right and
so the the whole idea that we are being
taken to task
or reading the unpeer-reviewed
literature as if peer review was any
good at all which it isn't right it's a
it's a it's a
um it's a negative influence for many
many reasons but the idea that we are
being taken to task nature is not being
taken to test because it obviously uses
the uh unpeer-reviewed literature and
the whole point here is to put a shackle
on our ankles not to actually apply some
standard generally but
um but the fact is look that literature
is what it is and yes you need to
realize that nobody has vetted it for
you but the vetting doesn't work so okay
there's a lot of there's a lot of chaff
in order to get to the wheat you got to
be better at it but that is the point
and who's going to be good at it
generalists that's right
uh
okay one more thing about Brookings yeah
before we before we leave this uh
someone pointed out to me online uh that
Brookings has been a
somewhat bot entity for a while now so
they pointed to this article you can
show this Zachary
um
this was in Washington Post in 2014's
this is a you know nine-year-old article
on basically the influence that is being
bought at Brookings and just a couple of
of things here
lobbyists say they warn clients not to
expect that they can dictate research
results from an elite Think Tank such as
Brookings but note that they gain a
chance to make their case directly to
researchers stay in touch as papers are
written and suggest participants in
public forums Whoa by enlisting
Brookings and other top-tier think tanks
quote you can amplify or raise an issue
said Ed Cutlery senior partner at
Mercury at public affairs and lobbying
firm that has developed expertise in
think tanks quote you can buy attention
but not a point of view or an outcome
so we have talked about the nature of
attention before you can take my screen
down now Zach uh and I could you really
really what I wanted to say is just read
this entire book this is the world
beyond your head by the awesome Matthew
Crawford on becoming an individual in an
age of distraction so this is the book
that followed his
um is amazing also amazing book
shopcraft is soulcraft
uh this this book explores the nature of
attention the attention economy uh the
fact that while we no longer are eagerly
putting up with having
polluted air polluted water a lot of us
still put up with toxins in our food and
our medicine but increasingly people are
thinking carefully about what is it that
we have changed in our environment that
is actually bad for us and and and
um
and making us crazy frankly he focuses
on attention in this book so just a
quick
um
excerpt from this book you can see if
you can see on the edge there you
probably can't see all the book darts uh
this this book is well worth book
darting and again I highly recommend it
when we go through airport security the
Public Authority makes a claim on our
attention for the common good this
moment is emblematic of the purpose for
which political Authority in a liberal
regime is originally instituted Public
Safety and rightly has a certain gravity
to it but in the last few years I found
I have to be careful at the far end of
the process because the bottoms of the
gray trays that you place your items in
for x-ray screenings are now papered
with advertisements and their visual
clutter makes it very easy to miss a
pinky-sized flash memory stick against a
picture of fanned out L'oreal L'oreal
lipstick colors
I was already on a state of low-level
Panic about departure times possible
gate changes and any number of other
contingencies that have to be actively
monitored while traveling to say nothing
of the fact that my memory is tapped out
with detailed concerns about the talk
I'm going to have to give in front of
strangers in a few hours this fresh
demand for vigilance lest I lose my
PowerPoint slideshow feels like a
straightforward conflict between me and
L'Oreal
somehow L'Oreal has a Transportation
Security Administration on its side
who made the decision to pimp out the
security trays with these advertisements
the answer of course is that nobody
decide on behalf of the public nobody
with a capital N someone made a
suggestion and nobody responded in the
only way that seemed reasonable here is
an inefficient use of space that could
instead be used to inform the public of
opportunities justifications of this
flavor are so much a part of the taken
for granted field of public discourse
that they may override our immediate
experience and render it unintelligible
to us our annoyance dissipates into
vague impotence because we have no
public language in which to articulate
it and we search instead for a diagnosis
of ourselves why am I so angry
that's fantastic
yeah
so I want to go one step farther before
we leave this topic
I want to talk about it attention is one
question here that what you read from
2009 wasn't it 14 14.
um that the 2014 Washington Post piece
on Brookings
um basically selling influence or having
access to influence and then the Matthew
Crawford book is 2015 it's just the next
year actually
so a there's a claim in there right oh
well you can buy attention but you can't
buy influence right the point is if if
it were this is the process of capture
taking place yes if the Brookings
institution was independent then it
could check the uh quality of work done
by others
that's a hazard if the work done by
others if you know Pfizer has purchased
bad work to advance dangerous products
and it has caused the New York Times to
be blind to the obvious indications that
there is a problem inside of the
connection between Pharma and science
right then the Brookings institution
could spot it well Pharma can't very
well tolerate that's what's going to
have to capture Brookings so I don't
know I don't know whether the connection
here is Pharma but the basic point is
look
you are watching a process unfold in
which something that could credibly tell
us that the system has been compromised
must itself be compromised so that will
not tell us that right of course you can
buy influence right once one of these
entities that has a financial interest
gets its way into these organizations
and the point is well you know how smart
do you have to be to realize that your
Grant is going to get funded if it leads
in a direction that is pleasing to the
funders rather than is not going to get
funded if it displeases them it's not a
hard thing for people to recognize and
so of course all of these things you
know can you can you buy influence over
a senator
that would be illegal right okay but are
there a thousand ways you know what can
you wink at a center Senator such that
they know that they're going to get a
certain job in the private sector that
isn't going to require a lot from them
and is going to spit a lot of money in
their Direction after they leave uh
Public Service you know it's sure hard
to prosecute you know is it you know
what did that wink mean oh I just had
something in my eye oh I guess you're
innocent right so again this list from
The Washington Post piece from 2014 on
um clients accessing research being done
at for Essence Brookings includes
making a case directly to researchers
staying in touch as papers are written
and suggesting participants in public
forums right and actually this goes back
to your uh however many months ago
you're talking about Ms magazine
abandoning uh advertisements because
although in theory The Advertiser should
have no influence on the content those
who work in these spaces know that that
can't be true yeah and that's you know
that's
yeah that's that's a that's a whole
other story specifically you know back
in the early 90s
uh advertisers felt you know back
advertisers felt that it was not just
acceptable but they got to demand that
they could skew editorial content
specifically in Publications that were
deemed women's Publications uh such that
you didn't feel a little icky or
challenged or uh or empowered really by
reading an article that might be next to
an advertisement for say L'Oreal right
and just to you know pick on the people
that Matthew Crawford already picked on
um
but it's the same for any of these
products right like the idea that if you
want to have if if you want to help this
publication survive well you get to
change what the publication is and not
have the readers end up empowered or
educated uh or upset or angry well then
uh the publication is no longer what it
was so basically you're buying an
audience that in by in in setting the
terms for what your what Your fees are
going to buy you are guaranteeing that
the audience will disappear right the
the audience that was there for
challenge for you know for Education
will not continue to stay for you know
cute stories about what lipstick to buy
or maybe they will
in which case your population becomes
dumber and dimmer and duller and less
able to tell the difference between
correlation and causation even when it's
spelled out very clearly and those
people sometimes get to write up reports
for the Brookings Institute which then
get empowered by the New York Times and
then you know attention that could be
coming to hey we'd like to help you
become better able to make sense of your
world that attention has been scooted
that way because we're apparently
dangerous zealots
well
um in some ways I think the overarching
uh conclusion here is that they are
making our point because our point from
the beginning has been
that the capture of the system by
perverse incentives is making the
information unreliable and putting you
in danger as you try to follow it
towards a reasonable course of action
and the point is what are the chances
that some report is going to come out
and say don't listen to those people
they are spreading misinformation and
then you scratch the surface and you get
a method and
pseudo-quantification the point is oh of
course because they've been captured how
could they not have been captured and
why can you guarantee that something
like that will be captured
0 is a special number right if there
were think tanks that were large and had
this Grand and premature that were
actually free to do their job we'd live
in a different world because they would
be commenting on all of the corruption
they would be calling it out they would
be and we would all subscribe to the
Publications that looked to those think
tanks to point the direction because
those things would be more reliable and
we'd be safer and better informed and
who doesn't want that and so the point
is this is the immune system of this is
the immune system of the corrupt
institution killing apparatus fighting
those who frankly have to be outside of
an institution even to do the work right
that's the thing we're out here uh
defenseless because it's the only place
the work can be done because otherwise
somebody says uh Dr hi I would like you
to sit down with our funder so that they
can you know Point your attention to
some issues with the research that
you're doing right and the point is well
where does that not happen well it
doesn't happen here right it doesn't
happen here and even the places that it
doesn't happen in institutions it could
suddenly start to happen it didn't
happen at Evergreen right like it was it
was why the place was so magical in part
because of the word remarkable
unprecedented otherwise unknown level of
autonomy that the faculty had to ask the
questions they wanted to ask to teach
the way they wanted to teach and to
engage with ideas and curriculum in ways
that may not have been Orthodox may not
have been seen before may not have been
standard and as long as you had respect
and honor and everyone ended up okay in
the end like good challenge make people
feel uncomfortable for sure you know and
you know because we were doing field
biology like we're going to take risks
of all the sorts and we're going to be
careful and we're going to make sure
that we plan a lot of things in advance
by making sure that you have on board
all of the tools that you need to make
decisions in tough situations but
ultimately this is about you and the
universe and
being honest about what you're seeing
and what you're doing and that's what we
continue to do now
after you know after the school went
insane and now after you know
the government and all the three layer
agencies have gone insane and we were
commenting on those things you know to
classes of 25 and 50 students for you
know a long time before we were doing
that to an audience here that was larger
than that of people we don't know but
you know the lessons are the same this
is not you know the idea that
uh you you the institutions are captured
and they are often doing exactly the
opposite of what they're claiming to do
is not dues to us like we've we were
saying those things to our students for
a very long time and it was okay to say
that at a school where uh we weren't
relying on for instance funds from the
NSF and NIH in order to pay our salaries
so in some sense you've got
a pattern we can observe what is taking
place here we can describe the pattern
and then it makes a prediction about
next time right yes if you are calling
out the capture of Institutions if that
if that institutional capture has
covered everything right then you will
be attacked by institutional stuff it
will attempt to portray you as
objectively off base
and when you scratch the surface you
will find in the methods that's
the prediction
every time
yeah
all right uh
there's a lot of other things we could
go to here but uh maybe we should uh you
had something something big and you said
you wanted to finish there but this will
take a while and when we when we save
the rest of what we might have done for
next week and
so I I do want to warn people there is a
way in which this could be us lost in
back and forth with online discussions
which don't matter it's not that I want
to talk a little bit about an
interaction that I've been having with
Scott Adams many people in the replies
to this interaction have alleged that
Scott is acting disingenuously that he
is not functioning in good faith I don't
know I don't see that in what he's
saying but maybe it's true it doesn't
matter what I want to do is recognize
that his questions to me actually
constitute a fantastic opportunity
whether they're genuine or not and I
sincerely hope that they are genuine but
whether they're genuine or not they do
lead us to exactly the right questions
that we need to be asking they speak in
a sense for a an audience that is
skeptical of us but might listen right
so Zach if you would put up the uh
thread that we have most recently been
interacting in
all right so here we have
Scott Adams so this is obviously
continuing from a different thread but
he says it's binary Brett either you
have a secret way of knowing the future
of long covid and also long-term vax
injury or you guessed about the risks
same as I did he's responding he's quote
tweeting me saying you are setting up
the problem incorrectly Scott Adams
putting your future self and your
followers at unnecessary Risk by doing
so if you'd like to discuss it I'm
willing assuming you'd rather know than
not know that is
okay my response to his uh claim that I
am guessing I say as I said you are
setting up the problem incorrectly it's
not a guess it's priors weightings and
evidence and then in parentheses hint
evidence is not synonymous with quote
data on a quote
it this can be explained well but that
is a very small fraction of the skill as
it is with archery painting and math
he responds
does your process not depend on knowing
the main risks
I respond to him not in the way you seem
to imagine I also don't depend on my
knowledge of chemistry to keep me safe
from poisons when I'm in a tropical
forest one could of course treat
everything as poisonous but that's not
what a good naturalist does
you discover patterns and methods
he says
this is where the rubber meets the road
science was invented so you wouldn't do
that I don't even know what that means
so you wouldn't I do so that I wouldn't
have to discover some methods well
that's just the thing interesting you're
confused in exactly the same way that I
was so I say to him fascinating it never
occurred to me that you'd think I was
describing an alternative to science
you have been misled Scott the grant
game has turned universities into a
racket big science is done by people
willing to attest that men can become
pregnant actual science is an art and
then I want to finish on my friend Creon
Levitt who responds
paraphrasing Galileo quote science is
poetry written about nature in the
language of mathematics then he quotes
Feynman for successful technology
reality must take precedence over public
relations for nature cannot be fooled
and then Creon says science is like an
art but unlike art its Supreme Arbiter
is nature and I believe Creon has
slightly misstepped here because I am
saying that the practice of science is
an art I am not saying science is Art
right
okay so what I wanted to do was proceed
from this a little bit I think what is
evident in Scott's complaint especially
where he says
science was invented so you wouldn't
have to do that where I'm saying look I
use something else to figure out where
the toxins are in a tropical forest and
he says science was invented so you
wouldn't have to do this I gotta say
like that I didn't I had not seen this
but if we're reading correctly what
he means there science is invented so
you wouldn't have to do what you and I
do and we're in tropical forests
I'm not much more scared for Humanity
than I was like I did not think I did
not think that we were there that
actually the Outsourcing of all of the
knowledge including the stuff that
actually people don't yet know was just
like that's that's a good that that's
like oh once once we've got it boxed and
it's been you know peer reviewed uh and
agreed and like rubber stamped well then
boom that's you just look at the you
look at the litany look at the list you
don't use first principles you don't
lose logic you don't keep your brain
alive and be thinking about
possibilities like no that's a known
thing
that's not that's not ever what science
is supposed to be doing for us right and
so this I thought was a terrific
opportunity because I don't think most
people really understand
what science is you know we could talk
about the scientific method but that's
too narrow that's not what science is at
a meaningful level right right so they
don't really know what it is that we are
claiming and so they do make missteps
like this by the way I forgot to mention
Creon Levitt is a NASA scientist so he
is a professional
um but anyway so I wanted to try a
little thought exercise because I
believe there's some things involved in
what you are called you and I are
calling science that are not narrowly in
the scientific method but are also not
the trappings of science they're what we
actually deploy right and I thought the
following
um thought experiment would reveal it so
the idea of not talked to you about this
before because I wanted it to be fresh
but the idea is Imagine for a second
that you and I were traveling by plane
over a tropical forest with which we had
no prior experience like Indonesia for
example we've spent no time in Indonesia
and suppose the plane goes down we
survive and nobody else does okay
so we're now in an Indonesian Forest
okay
um we don't recognize anything from our
direct experience we've never been in
any Forest near there right maybe
there's the occasional plant that's so
General that it has a relative there but
by and large everything would be new to
us and the question is uh well I was
thinking a little bit about the um the
movie The Martian where uh what's his
name Matt Damon Matt Damon at some point
at the point that he's facing that one I
have seen certain death
um uh says that he's gonna he's gonna
science the out of this planet
right which is something you know every
geek in the audience is like yeah
science the out of that thing
um but anyway the point is look you and
I would immediately without ever
mentioning science
start employing the process writ large
to the puzzle presented by well what the
hell are you going to do now that you
are in the situation and I wanted to
talk about what that is because I think
it brings in some of the elements that
Scott is missing here
so all right you got it in your mind
we've landed uh without you know with
some random collection of artifacts that
survived some plane crash nobody's
coming to help us
what do you do how do you engage the
problem
right so a you'd want to think about
what threatens you right and in what
order of priority I'll just be before
you start talking I will say that the
first two thoughts that come to mind are
do we have to engage the question of
cannibalism here
um
not between us but like the corpses nope
okay so we don't have to talk about that
you know we could but I don't know
everyone else is okay so we don't have
to go there
um and then you know if it's Indonesia
then of course one of the things that
comes to my mind is like are we on
Borneo or are we on one of the dinky
little Islands such that like actually
we're going to be at a coast and
thinking about uh you know setting up
flares to get the attention of other
people my intent here is that we are
lost let's say that you know
you're stuck
Rescuers come you'd see The Rescuers
land uh
and you're you know you're you're 10
kilometers out and you book it back as
fast as you can but by the time you get
there they're gone so you can infer they
have decided nobody survived this plane
crash
they're not coming back so you know you
have to survive by your wits and kind of
this habitat you don't know right
so anyway
a certain number of things before you
get to the sciency part are like okay
what am I threatened by in this habitat
right what is the order of priority of
the problems that I have to solve
what do I have at my disposal did
anything survive you know
um so let's just take for example
well you've got I mean
you think through the Hostile forces
right the you know the Hostile forces of
nature that that threaten you as a
surprisingly undefended human out in
nature which which doesn't happen to
most humans most of the time but you
know they're the abiotic ones right
there's there's weather and climate now
you're in the tropics so you're unlikely
to freeze to death but
um you know there's there's water levels
that change uh there's tree falls that
can happen that's biotic I suppose and
then over in biotic space you've got you
know people always are like oh you know
what's the big thing that's going to
come at you right like what's what's a
dangerous snake or the big carnivorous
and really those aren't those aren't the
things right so it's going to be
um it's going to be parasites
uh it's and it's going to be
um
chemical competition from Plants it's
going to be like poisonous spines and
thorns and uh and uh and little things
that could get you out of Defense rather
than things that are trying to make you
their lunch right so a couple things one
you're not going to freeze to death but
it doesn't mean you're not going to die
of exposure or short of dying of
exposure you could make problem number
two which is sustenance vastly worse in
other words to the extent that you are
burning hard-won food in order to stay
warm the point is you actually require
you're you're driving up your
requirements for nutrients yeah to the
extent that you could have sheltered
yourself and failed to yeah right so
assuming you have no ability to filter
water yep
you you know your your water your water
problem is going to be one uh that shows
up quickly and uh you you want to
carefully basically titrate water intake
uh sufficiently that you can know
relatively quickly is this Source gonna
make me sick
and if so I need to find another source
I would also say that there are some
things you can do to reduce the
likelihood that it's going to make you
sick I mean a you don't want stagnant
yeah you you look for the the clear like
Clarity of water is a good visual
indicator and flow and flow movement and
Clarity are good you know it just has
less particular matter in it it probably
has less stuff that you can't see in it
as well yep
um you could also one of the things that
I would think about doing since water is
unlikely to be limiting but drinkable
water might be
if you could either with something you
salvaged from the wreckage
uh carry small amounts of water so that
you could use UV light to purify them
right a very shallow bit of water can be
purified with UV light now if you're on
the forest floor
it's not like there's no light but it's
not intense right it's it uh I don't
know the Indonesian number when I was
working in Panama there were some plant
physiologists working on questions and
you know they did all kinds of
interesting things like put fisheye
lenses on the floor of a tropical forest
so they could actually monitor the
amount of light over the course of a day
because these light flecks sweep across
the floor as the sun moves right anyway
something like one percent of the
incident light the light that hits the
canopy makes it to the forest floor it's
a tiny fraction well but so you find a
light Gap so you find a place for one of
these um so we're in Indonesia
uh so we're like interestingly one of
the ways it's going to be different from
forest trouble for us we've been in is
that most of the trees are from the same
family it's all it's mostly the same is
it different carbs yeah um but still
they're gonna fall sometimes so you find
you find yourself a light Gap and maybe
you try to um
UV UV purify water by finding a shallow
pan into which you can put more
fashioning out of some of the fuselage
or something yeah exactly
um and so then you're gonna have to
transport it which is going to be a
waste of time and energy so you're going
to try to get efficient about that
you're going to try to find a get light
Gap or create a light Gap big enough to
do the job and anyway so okay that's
going to be one issue water
obviously for most of your needs it
doesn't need to be drinkable but the
drinkable stuff needs to be pure you
could use UV light
um
okay second thing
food
all right so it seems to me that well
did you you said something in that
thread right like I I maybe I inferred
because I know you know I do and you do
and you know we've been together
uh occasionally tasting of neo-tropical
forests
right near tropical neo-tropical forests
tasting in neotropical Forest I said
tasting of tasting of neotropical forest
I would rarely approach the forest and
taste the whole thing but you know the
tasting of not tasting the whole thing
tasting of and uh you know you do so
with
great care and parsimony and
um and a little bit and you wait and you
wait and you wait and you see and a
little bit more of anything now you
can't be as completely careful if you
have nothing if you know if if the when
the plane went down it took out all of
you know if you really have no food at
all
uh you know you have you have some time
but not a ton of time yeah to figure out
what all you can eat and uh it's it's
tougher to it's tougher to hunt than
people who have never hunted without the
tools that they are accustomed to
hunting with no uh but you know you
learn that but it's far easier to forage
so this is one of the things I was
hoping would emerge here okay
part of what it is to science the
out of a forest like this in order to
survive is taking a model that is robust
figuring out which elements of it apply
to your new situation and then applying
it in a way that you can reverse course
to the extent that you discover
something about the model isn't right
yeah so you and I have a method
right the method involves
the recognition that there are fruits in
a forest especially a tropical forest
those fruits are relatively easily
recognized you can identify a fruit
which does not mean you can eat it okay
some fruits are edible some fruits are
not edible not because they aren't
fruits designed to be eaten but because
the plant in question has decided to
exclude certain animals which are not
good dispersers in favor of other
animals which are this can be
um a trick as it is with chili peppers
where Chili Peppers give you the
impression that you are being damaged
like you're lacerating your mouth but
it's not true that is to that is
designed to drive away mammals and give
Birds this particular fruit but they're
not actually poisoning you right but if
you were to find a rando fruit in the
Indonesian Forest that you and I knew
nothing about right some little red
berry hanging off of something yeah
right one thing you could do is you
could take it and you could touch it to
your tongue well but before before you
do that you use your other senses right
um so you use the color and say okay
well if it's green actually it's either
not meant for me or it's not ripe yet
probably a no
uh if it's one of the colors that humans
tend to like in fruits okay maybe
although red fruits especially little
red berries are more often bird fruits
oh because birds see birds see red
particularly well you know even in the
in the dark understory if it has an
aroma
that smells while fruity Pleasant if it
smells Pleasant to you as a human being
that plant is communicating to you even
if it didn't know you were coming it
knew it was it was communicating to a
potential mammal disperser of of its
seeds and it's giving you the gift of
the fruit to entice you to disperse it
and if it smells like you know there are
in the Indonesian Forest there are like
these um corpse flowers right that
attract flies I guess that's the
pollination stage I don't even know what
the fruits of that plant look like but
I'll bet it's not about mammal dispersal
no I may be wrong but like you know if
the fruit smells like poop or a die in
Corpse like yeah that's that plant is
communicating something to you and maybe
the plant is trying to obscure that it's
got a great value there and you should
override your first reaction and go for
it but don't start there yeah for
example durian right durian famously has
a nasty smell but it's very good mammal
fruit
um so you could also you know do
something like uh if you were to observe
monkey
eating a fruit in a tree and very often
there's fruit dropped at the bottom of
the tree it's almost certain that that
fruit is going to be safe to eat
um from the monkeys invite them to do
well you can follow the monkeys around a
little bit that would be pretty useful
yep totally um your green fruit is a
great uh test case because one
hypothesis is that that green fruit is
not ripe and if you touch it to your
tongue you will get an astringent feel
or a very bitter taste and it will tend
to be hard right so touch as well so
gives you a sense the the key here is
that the model is fruits you shouldn't
eat give you a warning they have an
interest in you knowing very quickly
that you shouldn't eat them because the
whole reason that they're toxic is to
dissuade you and this and the the
conversation about fruits is going to be
different from
uh say you know
what else might you find that's not just
a whole organism
um well fungus a fungus right uh no
fungus has as a strategy to disseminate
itself in the world being eaten by
something
I think
I think that there are some occasional
things okay so it's a broadcast you can
assume that you run into a fungus you
might be able to eat it there's a really
good chance it'll kill you a decent
chance it'll get you high but there's
almost no chance if not no chance at all
that its strategy is to entice you to
eat it so that it can it you can help it
with its propagation into the world
whereas there are and we talk about this
in hunter-gatherers guy at the 21st
century there are very few things that
we eat that are actually designed by the
organisms to be eaten and fruit is one
fruit milk right and yeah fruit and milk
okay so it's funny but not by us by the
baby but if you can figure out how to
extract it the fact that I'm just saying
like honey honey is not designed to be
eaten by a mammal but it is designed as
food yeah
um okay so your green fruit hypothesis
is and hypothesis doesn't mean I believe
this to be true I mean this might be
true and so obvious it could be
the point is one hypothesis is that that
fruit is not ripe and that when it is
ripe it will be edible to me it will be
counterproductive if I eat it before
it's ripe now did we have the foresight
to crash uh with flagging tape or not uh
I would really like to Mark trees well
but we're going to get good at that yeah
that's part of the answer is that the
test for the hypothesis that that is an
unripe fruit that I can eat when it's
ripe is to keep checking up on it right
um the test for the hypothesis that that
fungus is edible to me right might
involve for me I would say watching an
animal that is similar to me
physiologically eat it
um and you know in you know this is a
survival question feeding it to an
animal right right now the question is
how do you feed it to an animal in this
Forest that might be a trick but yeah
that seems like a like that seems
several stages of unlikely but well but
there are ways you could do it you could
pair it with something right also it is
true that many things that are toxic can
be detoxified with methods that you
could innovate here so for example many
of the things like a potato is not a
good thing for you to eat but a potato
that has been boiled is a good thing for
you to eat unlikely to run into potatoes
in the Indonesian Forest no but you may
run into something that is potato-like a
storage organ and the cool place that no
that's also a new world anyway there's
there's some un there's going to be some
underground storage organ right plant is
storing energy for its own use does not
want someone else to come along and eat
it but may have put something in which
could be maybe it's
the proteins are toxin they can be
denatured by cooking them you can
denature them by cooking them or you can
dissolve them out with water those are
the two biggest or dissolve them out
with water and acid or right but
um also true that to the extent that
there's some number of calories that you
need
that number can be driven way down with
a technology that you would want for
this other purpose also which is fire
so I would argue one of your top
priorities if you think you're long-term
stuck in a situation like this
is how to make fire now let's say that
nothing from the plane gives us any leg
up in that regard well and you also you
know once once we start talking about
you know how how are we also going to
start getting meat uh which is going to
bring in a lot more calories you then
get a lot more nutrition out of the meat
um once once exactly so no you get more
calories out of the meat once you've
cooked it yeah you get more nutrients
out of the meat especially calories I'm
not I think the nutrient analysis may go
the other way but you get more calories
don't think so but anyway it's a it's an
interesting question but in any case you
need a source of fire okay you're in an
Indonesian alolan Indonesian Forest okay
one of the ways to make fire is out you
can't use an ice lens to uh a what an
ice lens the way you would use a
magnifying glass
maybe something from the airplane
yep yeah can be done yes I was not
imagining that you could yeah well it's
it's one of them even on my list of
possibilities okay so that leaves from
my perspective that leaves assuming
nothing from the plane uh is capable you
know there are no lighters or something
like that yeah you've got two options
and I think their priority reverses
based on what you did recover from the
plane
okay the two ways would be bow drill
um and fire plow
I don't know what a fire plow is fire
plow is basically a piece of wood that
you rake across a surface that you have
flattened and generate enough heat to
create a spark that can light some of
the fire starting material you know I
just saw a video just before it became
on why I was watching this video I'm not
sure
um this was in this is a an iron guy a a
an iron worker so he's got hard metal
surfaces but the the premise is you know
how do you start a fire with nothing but
mechanical force from a hammer now in
this case you've got you got two pieces
of metal so you know you don't have that
necessarily I mean you got the fuselage
of the plane or no I don't know what all
you got um but you know he's got some
anvil-like thing sorry I don't know the
language here he's got a hammer and he's
got some sticks and some paper and first
you know he
pounds the wood into lots of little
pieces and puts it aside and then he
takes just a like a poker and he just
pounds the poker with the hammer against
the other metal until the poker is hot
enough that it can set the paper on fire
that that can stop the kindling I could
totally see it using mechanical force to
start a fire right and a fire plow
basically allows you to do the something
like this with wood where you can create
enough friction now of course the whole
thing is dependent on I've now forgotten
what the term is for the stuff that you
accumulate that lights very easily
because once you have a little bit of
forest fluff lit then you can wipe
I don't know don't know what Tinder yeah
I guess Tinder is probably the the right
term there may be another term in the
case of of bow drills and stuff but
anyway
um
one of the key things to do one of the
things that I would do first in this
scenario
is find stuff that looks like it should
be flammable and put it in a place that
it will continue to get drier and drier
and drier no matter what the weather
does right because that's going to be
the hard but often you can find stuff
that will burn but it's too wet in the
state that you find it and so yeah
um well and that's you know one of one
of the things
one of the things that will be
challenging in such a situation which
won't be obvious to people who haven't
spent a lot of time in lowland tropical
rainforests which say jungles is how wet
everything is even even if it even if
you're in a little mini drought and it
hasn't actually rained for three weeks
and there's no sign that it's going to
rain again it's still just wet
everything is wet and it gets wetter and
so you know the things we haven't talked
about is like how do you keep how do you
keep the fungus away how do you keep the
pathogens away like how do you keep
yourself you know free of the organisms
that want to encroach on you that aren't
the big charismatic things that want to
bite you and eat you for lunch but you
know it's it's the oh my foot's gonna
fall off because I had a tiny little
wound and now something has gotten into
there and oh gangrinous yeah so it's not
your first priority after the plane
crashes but it's very high on the list
that you figure out how to generate fire
and the thing about generating fire is
it's very very difficult however
it is much easier and I think would be
one of the you know top three or four
jobs in the whole how do we keep
ourselves a live scenario is starting
fire very very tough however many hours
it takes you it's worth it once you've
got the fire started keeping it alive
enough that you can constantly revive it
is going to be the key to survival what
you don't want to have to do is restart
it more times than you need to right you
want to be able to revive it and that
means in this scenario
you're going to have to start banking
dry fuel so that you can keep something
on it and if you have to go out for
three or four hours to go look for food
when you come back there's enough of a
smoldering which also means you need a
place to burn it that if it rains it
doesn't suddenly turn to Mush but anyway
you would start looking for these things
um your point about meat is a good one
one of the things you know part of the
scientific model that you would bring to
this forest in which you knew none of
the creatures is the idea that meat is
edible right there are a couple of
mammal species and at least one bird
species that have toxins
as far as I know the pitahui bird is
toxic and I think it's just the feathers
isn't it I'm not sure yeah um but you
know if we crash we wouldn't have we're
not going to crash at a library so you
can't look it up
um okay okay we'll take pitahui off our
list if yeah well if we can even
recognize it particularly but the point
is
um you know for the ratio of edible
Birds if I remember correctly it's the
same Toxin and I think it's just the
feathers in pitahui as is in the poison
frogs that I studied was that right yeah
it's this these lipophilic alkaloids
that you really don't want to ingest
because that's an unpleasant death uh it
would all there are some creatures that
are very
um
distasteful right herbivores we talked
about this fullivores often take in so
many toxins that their meat is
disgusting yeah um but probably edible
probably okay yeah um but you probably
want to switch to something else as
quickly as possible because the cost of
detoxifying what you would I mean that's
one of the things this is really what
this discussion is about
do you need to reduce your level of
toxins that you take into zero no
your your liver and your kidneys and
other aspects of your physiology can
deal with low levels of toxin what you
don't want to do is take in a lot of any
particular Toxin and certain toxins are
white bat even in tiny amounts which is
why if you if you don't know your fungus
and most people have just don't know
anything close like you that's that that
comes last on your list of dietary
preferences because the toxins that can
that are in so many of the ones that you
that you shouldn't be eating are you
know are enough to hurt you at a very
low dose yeah very low dose you can take
out your liver and there's no coming
back from that in a scenario like this
and it you know frankly even the
hallucinogens are bad for you in this
scenario yeah um because you you can't
afford the confusion
um but that said if you know if
you watched a mammal consume a
significant amount of a mushroom you
could experiment with a tiny amount of
it and see whether it made you sick is
that sure not to kill you I wouldn't say
so but the point is uh a maybe you just
discover you know if it's a fungus and
it's consumed by mammals and you try a
little bit and it doesn't make you sick
hey you may have just increased the
number of things in that Forest you can
eat to something that replenishes that
you can readily recognize it doesn't run
away not very fast at any rate
um so
did you have something else you wanted
to add there so anyway my point here is
science
observe hypothesize predict test is a
smaller piece of a larger picture repeat
repeat repeat but the point is the whole
point of that exercise is not the
production of so-called data right the
the point of the exercise is the
production of models
I don't mean computer models you and I
are both very skeptical of computer
models because it's very easy to fool
yourself or others by adding in enough
parameters that the model uh spits out
plausible sounding answers for no good
reason well and you you add assumptions
in the same way you add data and
generally you're generating neither the
assumptions nor the data and so you've
just like it's not it's not your own
work in the same way going like okay I
have my biases and I'm you know walking
around with some assumptions some of
which aren't yet explicit but as you
know as
my hit rate goes down I have to go back
and try to figure out which of my which
what assumptions I don't even know exist
I'm working from and get rid of them one
by one and I mean it's like it's it's
the science version of an Elimination
Diet right
um and and you know figure out what you
need to do to get what your experience
to a greater and greater match for
reality
so
you do this process it generates models
those models are not an exact mirror of
reality and in fact in the scenario that
I picked for us here be very different
if we crashed in a neo-tropical forest
even a neotropical forest that we didn't
know has continuous of many of the
creatures that we do know yeah and we
know something about their behavior you
know if they're animals which might
allow us to search for them more
narrowly and
um you know you know you and I would
know that a capybara is good eating
right that's something you would know as
for you know a sun bear a how dangerous
is it and B how good is it to eat that's
a tougher one right it's not it's not a
familiar creature to me other than just
to know that it exists
um yeah yeah but yeah they like avocados
Oh no you're talking about spectacle
Bears yeah Oh I thought you were still
in the neotropical forest you're talking
about spectacle bears in the natural
well first I was talking about the I was
thinking you could follow spectacle
Bears to the avocados well and that's
the thing is if we were in a neotropical
forest yeah you know
I would know how to find figs probably
whether you could access them be
dependent on who's feeding on them
because they're too high yeah uh
spondius you know there are all kinds of
things that I would go looking for
quickly but in a forest I really didn't
know you could you the point is how good
is my model well if I crashed in Brazil
it's better yeah if I crash in you know
some other parts of Sumatra it's worse
but it's not nothing it's certainly good
enough to begin to set out a plan for
how to allocate my time and my effort
and what risks to take in order to solve
the problems that accompany survival
which would be
don't die of exposure don't spend more
energy on staying warm than you need to
don't squander the resources that are in
an animal that you have uh killed by
failing to cook it properly don't risk
taking on the parasites by not cooking
it you know some things that you can't
another reason to cook yep some things
that you can't eat could be rendered
edible if they can be boiled some things
that you can't eat can be rendered
edible if you can cook them the point is
that General model most of those
parameters are not things that we
discovered on our own in a survival
scenario they are things that we have
come about through
studying scientifically through coming
to understand what the underlying
mechanisms is the idea that a plant
might want you not to eat its storage
organ and it might fill it with toxins
but if those toxins are water soluble
that you have a way of extracting them
and leaving the nutrients right this is
the scientific model that you would
crash in the forest with and and in this
case
trusting what your senses are telling
you with regard to aversions and disgust
and preferences and such makes good
sense it that will be a less good guide
the more hyper novel your environment is
but just as we talked about with regard
to fruit you know if it smells good to
you if it if it looks appealing and
smells good and uh you know feels good
in the hand is less of a thing but like
if it feels ripe because you've eaten
fruit before and you know what ripe
tends to feel like and you taste a
little bit of it and it tastes sweet to
you still don't eat the whole thing all
at once right but if you've got all
these other sensory modalities telling
you you know what this feels right this
feels good there's a really good chance
that that is consistent with this is a
fruit this is the fruit of a plant that
benefits When mammals eat the fruit and
disperse the seeds and therefore this is
not going to hurt you because it was
made effectively for you right and the
ability to to override your intuitive
sense of how something smells or tastes
in the case that you have evidence that
it might be all right anyway is
important too so the point is you crash
in the forest in Indonesia with a crude
model and then you use science to
improve that model so that when you
happen onto some durian right the point
is you're not dissuaded by the fact that
it smells bad you know from having
watched a mammal eat it and then having
tried it on your your own and feeling oh
that was pretty good that that satisfied
me and it didn't make me sick right the
point is your model gets better and
better you become expert in your local
habitat and how to
deal with it and so yeah all right I
think we're I think we're more or less
there the point is you've been misled
the degree to which you think that
science is about Laboratories and uh
peer review and studious discussions and
high-tech equipment and that to the
extent that that thing grant money
doesn't work
um you're just out of luck you have
been lied to the proper scientific
thinking is a cultivated way of looking
at the world and you know I was reminded
as I was thinking about us doing this
exercise
that we actually did a podcast back in
Portland in which we talked about this
and we said look you misunderstood
science for us we are much more likely
to be doing science in rubber boots with
machetes than we are to be in a
laboratory or looking through a
microscope doesn't make it less
scientific the point is it's the same
mental process being deployed in a very
different scenario one in which you
cannot drive all of the noise out that's
what a laboratory is is a noise remover
that allows you to focus in on a
phenomenon and that predicts maybe that
field biologists regardless of whether
they think about Evolution or geology or
ecology or whatever might actually be
better suited to the complexity of
something like a novel coronavirus and a
novel set of vaccines and repurposed
treatments and a political response then
laboratory scientists might be because
laboratory science is precisely about
reducing the number of variables
so that when you get a result you're
more and more confident that it's
because of the thing that you
manipulated whereas field science
can not have most of its variables
controlled so you get accustomed to the
the practice of engaging in a field
science is one in which you have to
figure out on your own what of the vast
amount of noise that I'm experiencing is
actually the pattern that I should be
honing in on and what of it might be
relevant but not right now and what if
it is not what it seems and also I can
ignore it right and
um
so the laboratory is very good at
removing the noise which allows you to
see very subtle
principles yeah you get you you often
get greater Precision you do yeah you do
um and sometimes you need that Precision
in order to see some very subtle
contributor to a process right point is
when somebody says
um I would like to inject you with this
liquid which contains some mRNA messages
which are going to hijack a certain
number of your cells and it's going to
cause them to produce a fragment of a
pathogen and the hope is that that is
going to make you immune if you
encounter that pathogen because it's a
bad one right the point is which is the
better model here the purified
laboratory where the point is oh the
only thing is going on in my experiment
are those tiny few things that I allow
to be there or
the did you just say you're going
to eat have you ever tested this on a
person have you ever do you have a
successful such a vaccine based on this
technology that you've ever deployed in
a human being how many of those causal
lengths that you said with authority are
actually black boxes in which you're
kind of crossing your fingers behind
your back going like I really hope it
works the way we say it does but the
fact is that we can't possibly have the
level of certainty that we claim to
which right away tells anyone who is
watching you make the claims okay
you are at the very least overstating
what you know right why would you be
overstating what you know
let's figure out what you actually could
know and see if you're ever saying some
of the things which you could know also
not saying some of the things you
definitely should know at this point
what else is inconsistent and on it goes
right and so you know the
straightforward argument is look you are
talking about introducing something
novel to my physiology
as if you understand my physiology which
I know you don't
nobody understands my physiology not
because I'm special but because human
physiology is complex mostly black boxes
we're very new at this and the degree to
which we understand is far outstripped
by the degree to which we do not yet
understand and so the point is you're
talking about intervening and it's every
bit is idiotic as if you walked into a
tropical forest and said let me explain
to you how this place works the answer
is oh are you from the future because
nobody in the present knows how this
thing works right we know certain things
but we do not know how this works and
so anyway and yet and yet we can apply a
scientific understanding of the world
and of the forest to have a better
chance of surviving a plane crash there
than if we said well
if I don't have you know if science
doesn't already know exactly what's
going on here I guess I'll just lay down
and die like those are two extreme
responses neither of which is Savvy or
smart or wise yeah now if we ever do
find the scenario unfolding first thing
I'm going to say to you at the point
that we wrestle ourselves free of the
somehow miraculously mostly unscathed
even though everyone else is dead okay
that's what I'm shooting for if that
happens right the first thing I'm going
to say to you is well welcome to complex
systems
it probably is yes yes
okay welcome to complex systems here we
go complex systems here we are
um
cool
well I think that's it I think we're
there I think we're there we will be
back next week and uh next week we'll
have a q a we're not going to do one
this week we encourage you to uh you
know check out 100 gatherers Guide to
the 21st century because a lot of what
we were just talking about is either in
there or or this discussion was highly
relevant to the toolkit that we that we
introduced and if you are thinking it is
too late no most of the 21st century
still lies ahead there's plenty of time
to get that book read it think about
what's in it and you can deploy it
scientifically as you deal with your own
plane crash sorry I mean be honest with
yourselves if you're watching this and
paying attention what are the chances
that you survive into the 22nd century
pretty low right wow
yeah no I mean I think our our producer
here our son who was born in 2004 should
uh should definitely shoot for that but
it's uh
yeah so for for the vast majority of our
audience it's not gonna happen sorry uh
so you know check out 100 gathers who
had the 21st century also it's true that
hunter-gatherers go to the 22nd century
probably most the same things will apply
even more so yes it'll be hyper hyper
novelty yeah uh if if we're still around
and uh we'd like for that to be the case
not us individually but Humanity doing
what humans do when we're at our best
largely with the help of the dogs
okay until we see you next time be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside be well everyone
[Music]